hi everyone
my name is chad and thanks for joining
us and today we're going to talk about
reinventing
geospatial analytics um and i'm joined
today
by joe betridge from telus and the the
key
point of this talk is going to be to
describe what becomes available to users
and customers and their users
when you really take the breaks off
geospatial analytics
hi there i'm joe betridge i lead the
telus insights consulting
program at telus we are a heavy user
of google bigquery as well as bigquery
gis
right on and uh joe and i are both
excited to uh
to show you what we've been up to uh so
yeah here are the two of us uh
we're gonna we're your speakers i'm a
product manager
at bigquery and i'm also the gis lead
for google cloud
and i am the consulting practice lead
for telus insights
right on okay so without further ado
let's go ahead and get into it
um we'll talk about use cases and
uh joe is going to go through some of
like the the algorithms that
telus is using inside of bigquery gis
but to set that up
i'm going to go through a couple call it
terms of art we're going to go through
bigquery just a little bit
and what bigquery gis is and then we're
going to get into
some more details so if you're already
very familiar with the pro with the
product
um you know just put me on one and a
half times speed for the next
minute and a half so with that let's
jump in
for those not familiar bigquery is
google cloud's
enterprise data warehouse so looking at
the left side of the screen here
we're primarily an analytics tool
and the product's real claim to fame
here is that we can scale from gigabytes
to
petabytes without
encumbering the user with having to
manage any of
that infrastructure you interact with
the product
in sql so it essentially looks like a
relational database that can scale
up to petabytes data inside of bigquery
is encrypted
durable and the product is highly
available as a matter of fact we
just launched um four nines of
availability as our new
sla which is industry leading which is
really cool
we want to make the product as
differentiated and useful to users as
possible so we have a couple unique
items that i wanted to talk about
the fact that bigquery is fully managed
and serverless
is the are those are the things that
enable us to
scale to petabytes without making users
provision hardware and things of that
nature
we have a real-time streaming api so you
can stream data straight into bigquery
and then using the bi engine which is on
the bottom of the list here
you can actually query that in real time
so you can do real-time insights on data
stream
right into your data warehouse without
having to use any other tools
we've also invented some new sql verbs
so that you can do machine learning
right inside the platform and what this
talk is all about
is some other sql verbs we didn't invent
them we're using the post gis
syntax but by bringing geospatial
sql functions and geospatial data types
into bigquery we're enabling a whole new
class of use cases inside the product
so let's dive in what is bigquery gis
first and foremost it's supporting a new
geography
data type we launched this to alpha a
couple years ago in 2018 it's since gone
ga
so this is a very solid offering inside
the product
and a geography data type as you can see
can have several different shapes
points line strings polygons multis
collections
all of these fit inside the geography
data type
to operate on those data types we have a
number of different functions so we've
got about
50 or so uh post gis
syntax functions that we've implemented
inside of bigquery
and these function types take the
categories here
and they cover the primary and the
majority of the functionality that folks
use inside of post gis
what's really exciting about some of
these though is that particularly the
predicates you can do geospatial joins
based on predicates so if you want to
join two tables based on whether a point
is inside a polygon
that is totally uh within bounds
if you want to do that on data sets that
are really big like
terabytes or hundreds of terabytes that
also is totally within bounds
and joe is going to talk a little bit
more about what becomes possible
when those limits are relaxed for your
workloads
speaking of workloads almost any
analytics workload whether it's
geospatial or not
has these components first thing you
need to get data into
your product or into the data warehouse
so that's the ingest here then you have
to analyze it inside the data warehouse
and then you know results as a table are
interesting for some result sets i
suppose
but really you want to visualize that
and particularly for geospatial
you want to visualize those on a map and
so
i wanted to call these out because there
are some aspects here that bigquery and
bigquery gis are really strong at
and there are some places where we need
our partner tools
to really flesh out these workflows so
i'm going to go through from left to
right
so in ingest bigquery has a load api
and a streaming api and so if you want
to
a lot of our for example industrial iot
customers are using the streaming api to
stream
instrument or sensor data straight into
bigquery tables
we have customers using the bigquery
load api to load
as much as a petabyte per day and we
have customers using the streaming api
to load up to tens of or 10 gigabytes
per second per table so that handles
data that's
um you know that we just want to flow
straight in but let's say you
have data sets that are in specific
geospatial formats
for that we've partnered with safe
software and they have written a
bigquery emitter for their tool
fme so this tool allows you
to import and materialize as a bigquery
table
any number of the hundreds of geospatial
formats that they support
so if you've got shape files or kml or
geojson or
what have you you know you know
geospatial data format
x chances are fme supports it and you
can bring that
straight in using a drag and drop tool
into bigquery
so ingest cool stuff now
the real strength of bigquery shows up
in this analyze column
in that big query as i mentioned before
the strength of this product is that it
can
um it can process data at the petabyte
scale
and so when you add geospatial analysis
to this
you can now process gis data at the
petabyte scale which really hasn't been
possible before
and so this type of data i'm really
talking about structured and
semi-structured data
for imagery data we have to turn to
tools like google earth engine
and descartes labs and i'll talk about
those in a little bit more detail later
so once you've done your analysis let's
move on to
serve and visualize specific or
particularly with geospatial
analyses you don't look at a table right
you want to see your results on a map
and we have a multitude of tools some of
them specified for different personas or
different types of users
to put those results in a map and then
serve them either as a report or as a
portal
or just as an image for that analyst
the ones i've highlighted here in bold
are ones that have direct connectors
to bigquery so you don't have to extract
a file
and then transform a file and then
render it so
there's a healthy selection of folks
that connect directly to bigquery
so let's talk about a couple of these
tools in detail
first off let's talk about google earth
engine as it performs on
imagery analytics so earth engine is a
tool
a product at google it's been around for
about 10 years
and it has an immense data catalog of
satellite imagery
it's about 30 petabytes and the thing
that's really cool about their
data catalog is that when new satellite
imagery comes in
earth engine as a service will
automatically register and orthorectify
that imagery
so that is includable in your analysis
with a single line of code so for
example like pound include for those
that speak c right
pound include sentinel imagery from
this date you know date a and boom
that's it and now you've got the entire
globe of central imagery from that date
you can then include central imagery
from date b
to do an a b comparison again with just
a couple lines of code
very cool stuff descarte labs
is another image processing tool that
connects directly to bigquery
they themselves have an immense data
catalog and some of these uh
thumbnails here uh describe elements of
it
um for example like sar imagery um ais
which is automatic indep actually i've
forgotten the acronym to that
um but that one's actually ship
positions uh showing shipping lanes all
over the world
um they also have a dedicated solutions
team so if there's an
aspect of this data that you want to
process
and you need some support descartes labs
has a lot of
detailed expertise to help you along
so the next few slides we're going to
step in and kind of go
persona by persona so analysts
if you're an analyst you speak sql
you're using bigquery
you know you look in the documentation
you figure out which st commands you
need
and you write your query and you just
want to see those results on a map
to understand understand what your
results are
bigquery geoviz is an excellent tool for
that so
you can either write the query in the ui
and then there's a drop down where you
can explore it directly in geofizz you
can compose your query in the geoviz
window which then runs it against
bigquery
and then that allows you then to do
interactive styling
um and visualization pan and zoom this
is all on top of google maps
we've also done a bunch of upgrades to
this little product over the last few
months so we've blown away
the visualization limitations and so
it's essentially
you can render as many points as your
browser can hold
and we've enabled the ability to share
maps with colleagues
so this is not a full-featured
geospatial analysis
platform like i said it's a way to get
your query on a screen so you can
understand it
but it's a handy little tool that we
like quite a lot
so for developers bigquery gis is also
supported by the google maps api so you
can bring bigquery data straight
into your map applications and map
visualizations
so you can see here this is actually a
heat map of taxi trips
in manhattan so that center image is the
island of manhattan
and then the api has some really nifty
ways to call out specific areas which
are shown in the two images
on the right now business users if
you're not an analyst and you're not a
developer
and you just want to operate in a bi
tool again we've got you covered here
both data studio and looker
have support for bigquery gis types or
bigquery geography types
and so you can use these tools to create
dashboards
on top of pan and zoomable maps
now one element that we haven't touched
on yet
that i'm very excited to announce today
right now
in this section is the carto tiler
with bigquery you have the ability to
process enormous
volumes of data the tools that i've
shown you before
are very very capable but they don't
have the ability to
render the same level and say magnitude
of volumes of data
that bigquery can and carto our partner
has solved that and what they've done
with the cardo tyler
is they've created a way to create a
hierarchy
of data it's corresponding to zoom
levels here
so what you're seeing in the right image
is
the building locations pulled from the
open street map data set which
incidentally is available in bigquery
public data
so you can create this map as well and
there are 300 million dots
worldwide on this map and so
if we click into that map you can see
how fluid and detailed the rendering is
as you go from street level
all the way back out to orbit and as
again we're announcing this
uh the availability of cartos beta today
there are some links over here
on the left hand side so you can play
with this map yourself and there's a
email address there for you to send a
note to to get more information
so just in case you thought the carto
tiler
only worked on points here's an example
on
polygons so we're going to zoom in here
again on new york where the southwest
corner
has some really interesting shaped uh
apartment buildings
so the the links here are on the slide
on the bottom left
and we are very excited to announce this
with our partner
carto as now visualization
has can approach the same scale as
bigquery's native compute
so very exciting stuff thank you
all right the last section before i hand
it off to joe is i wanted to talk at a
high level
about the use cases that we are seeing
our customers employ
bigquery gis so starting on the left
hand side
in retail the primary operations in
retail that we've seen
are channel optimization site selection
and marketing analysis by trade area
because bigquery allows you to define
your own polygons obviously
like you can define your own data driven
trade areas
rather than using the established ones
like either census blocks or
zip codes or any other kind of
established polygon you can define your
own that are specific to your business's
needs
and then run whatever aggregations you
need again because the scale will
support you
in supply chain and logistics we've seen
a number
of our customers use
iot so internet of things data to do
traffic analysis which is what this
image shows
this is actually a heat map of ml
predicted hazardous driving areas
developed by our partner and customer
geotab
so they actually used vehicular data
combined with
weather data that's already stored in
bigquery to do a gis
plus machine learning tool to
say you know you can dial in a weather
condition and then have that
predict what the hazardous driving would
be for that weather condition
so very useful for city planners and
traffic planners
we see a lot of activity around delivery
optimization
and really gratifyingly we're seeing
some uh
significant projects around supply chain
sustainability
so this is calculating the human cost
the economic cost and the environmental
cost of taking product from
its source which may be many many
thousands of miles away from its
ultimate destination
on the shelf before you buy it and so
knowing the true cost of that supply
chain and being able to optimize that
supply chain to make it
economically environmentally sustainable
is really exciting work
we all know how important dissemination
public dissemination of data is in this
time
and age and so we've seen a number of
u.s states and countries around the
world
use bigquery gis and our dashboarding
tools
to support public data portals
also very interestingly this is an air
quality map
from our colleagues at aklima and geotab
where they're actually discovering one
that air quality can change on a block
by block
basis and two that the rest or the
reduction
in human travel during these coveted
times
has greatly reduced the pollutants in
the air
um and they have a lot of research that
they've used bigquery and bigquery gis
to support
and then lastly in agriculture we've
seen a lot of usage
around a yield optimization so trying to
get the most
food production out of a field that you
possibly can
and then once you've figured it out for
the field because these tools bigquery
and in this case earth engine
operate at such scale you can do these
analyses for the entire globe in one
shot
and so that way s4 agtech another one of
our customers
is doing worldwide production
forecasting um
you know where like figuring out how
much grain the ukraine is going to do is
just one step
of their process because they can do
that for the ukraine for argentina
the entire globe in one shot
so with that let me wrap up my section
i've given you a very high level
introduction to both bigquery bigquery
gis
and some of the partner ecosystem and
use cases
and i'd like to hand it over to joe now
to tell you
what telus is doing in detail
perfect thank you for that chad uh so
just to get us started uh for those of
you who are not from canada and don't
know who telus is telus is one of the
largest telecommunication companies
within canada
so we represent about nine and a half
million of the 35 million canadians
on their cellular plans
and one of the things we've been doing
for the last while is we've been
developing an insights product that
allows us to use
massive amounts of de-identified
aggregate data to answer
really complex questions about the real
world and what we want to announce today
is that we're creating an api
into this data that is launching today
that allows for users to query this data
directly
and get aggregate results back that have
no individual information in them but
can answer really complex business
problems
this is a first for us and it's one of
the first times in the world that an api
into this type of
data has been able to be generated and
that's thanks to bigquery gis
so the big picture of what we're trying
to do is we're trying to solve the
problem that many businesses have today
of making critical decisions
based on gut feel small sample rate
surveys and strongman business cases
we've had this promise of big data for a
very long time yet we haven't seen a lot
of delivery on it we've just seen mass
and mass amounts of data be stored
but no real analysis has been capable to
be completed that can really solve the
questions that businesses and
governments have
usually this is for one of two reasons
either the technology's a roadblock
or privacy has been a roadblock and as i
was talked about in the next few slides
both of these things have been solved
using both bigquery and the previous
groundwork we've laid around privacy
and we need this to be scalable this is
a really critical issue
government's existing bi tools need to
be integrated and needs to be able to be
used within the current supply
chain of data we can't be trying to
create a new set of tools
we need integrations directly to the
tools today as chad was talking to
earlier the bigquery gis is really great
for plugging into a lot of different
tools that we commonly use
so what is telus insights uh telus
insights takes all the aggregate
information being generated by your
cellular network so every time a phone
connects to a cell tower
uh there's a residual event that's
created that says this phone was at this
cell tower at this time we take all that
information across the country
we remove all the identifiers we get rid
of anything that's personal from that
and we create a row level record saying
this is the data of what happened across
canada
we then upload that data into the cloud
process it
remove a lot of the secondary
information that's not necessary
and then we start analyzing it and
producing insights these insights could
be
that there were 10 000 people in a
neighborhood at a time that spent at
least two days there in the last week
it could be the trade area of a given
business
maps around a certain area the primary
area of trade is within five kilometers
of the business the secondary area
is within seven kilometers to the east
and only three kilometers to the west
we're able to pull this all out and
aggregate that through
um and finally we're doing these results
through an api um that's powered by
google cloud and all of this we need
privacy
privacy is a critical cornerstone of
everything we do around
insights telus has worked very closely
with ann kavukian who's the former
privacy commissioner of ontario
on achieving privacy by design
certification
this certification entails ensuring that
all privacy and regulatory
issues are met the language she wrote
has influenced the gdpr
and has been seen there throughout what
we do specifically is we add in
privacy controls including
de-identification so before we analyze
any data we're de-identifying it
we aggregate all of our information into
large data pools so we don't allow
anything about individuals or even small
groups of individuals
further to this we extrapolate all the
data to match to our market share so it
represents the entirety of the country
as opposed to only telus's share
we also include security within this we
do a lot of work on security and making
sure this product is secure by design
all engagements beyond this are also
audited by our trust model
telus views trust is a cornerstone of
all privacy if you don't have trust you
can't have privacy
and how we gain trust is through being
transparent so we
update all our privacy policies to
include what we're doing with
de-identified and aggregate data
we also understand that not a lot of
people read privacy policies so one of
the things we've done to help this is
we've added privacy frequently asked
questions on our
website that are written in very plain
and simple language that help everyone
understand
exactly what we are doing and finally we
give users control so we give users the
ability to opt out of any of these
large-scale analyses
without asking them for reasoning or
justification it's just a simple opt-out
if they choose to do so
with this being said i'm going to take
you through our architecture very
briefly and talk through a bit of what
we do
specifically with the data so all this
data is captured with probes within our
network
i'm not going to go into detail about
how that works but once that data is
landed on a server it's pushed out to
google cloud using nifi
once it lands there it's put into a data
flow job and that data flow job
removes all the opted out information it
sanitizes and de-identifies it strips
out all the personally identifiable
information from the data
and then it does some analysis to retain
secondary traits of that data so this
could be things like area codes or the
country origin of a device that are
stored within that personal information
but are not the entirety of that data
once all this has been stripped down to
the skeleton of the information
it's landed into bigquery where further
analysis is done to remove things like
duplicate devices um undesirable devices
these might be things like roaming
devices from
an iot device that's not actually part
of what we're looking to analyze
as well as we generate a system-based
universal
unique identifier so this identifier is
generated by the system as the only
identifier associated to any of the
information from this point forward
meaning there's no tie back to any of
the personal information
once this is done our data is pushed
through to an analysis layer at this
layer
we do a lot of different work to reduce
the amount of data that we're storing
so this includes collapsing down uh each
device into a timeline of
what happened to that device as opposed
to all the individual events
we also calculate an assumed home and
work neighborhood we'll talk a bit more
about how that works and how we preserve
privacy in that step
on the next slide we also then include a
geo id to each location which is used to
apply market share and finally we
compute all of our api queries against
this aggregated data set
so our final layers are output layer and
this layer is build map engine and it
allows users to query and ask
things like what are the number of
visitors in a given polygon at a given
time
and they get a result returned back from
that from the analysis layer
all of these results meet our privacy
thresholds and are about large aggregate
groups
we'll talk a bit more about how this is
utilized in some real world cases in a
couple slides
so the first thing i want to talk about
is our assumed home and work
neighborhood analysis
so the first thing we do is we look at
what towers the device connected to over
a period of time in this given example
we're going to look at a one week period
in this image we can see two distinct
clusterings of towers that this device
were to have connected to during the
time the first one being on the left
here
and the second being on the right the
one on the left has a much higher total
time
spent so we're going to look at that
cluster specifically and there's a lot
of research that's showing the time most
spent
in a given area is likely that home or
the home is likely within that area
so taking this cluster we're going to
place a polygon
around the initial tower with the
highest weight we then are going to
shuffle that polygon
across the different towers to try to
find a closer
representation of where the home area is
so we continue to shift this
towards the higher weighted towers until
we eventually hit that lowest weighted
tower
and get a rough estimate of where the
home neighborhood would be
from here we overlay that polygon onto a
set of polygons that are based around
canadian
statistics canada information
of where neighborhoods are so these are
important neighborhoods they're using
statistical analysis of demographics
and what we use for our market share so
by applying these neighborhoods we use
an st within function to determine
exactly where that polygon is
and then we only store that blue polygon
that is much larger as the home area for
that device
this again strips away us storing any of
this information that's really detailed
and we go to this higher level piece of
information
to just understand the neighborhood
which is used in that further analysis
one of the big projects we've had come
online since covit 19 started is our
data for good program
within this program we're providing
governments as well as
academic institutes access to our
information at the aggregate and
de-identified
layer uh to help them solve problems
related to covid19
this could be things ranging from how
healthcare should be impacted and what
should be done for healthcare institutes
through economic recovery as we're
trying to reopen our economy
we're doing this under a strict set of
rules which are outlined on our data for
good website
these include things like these cannot
be used for police enforcement
the data cannot be used in any way
outside of the
typical usage we have outlined within
our privacy policies
we will not reduce any of our privacy uh
thresholds for covid19 we are staying
strict everything we've
uh transparently given to our customers
going forward
but this has been a very powerful
offering that many of our provinces
federal government and several cities
are using as well to try to help in the
fight against covid within canada
this is one specific example of how this
data can be used this is looking at
social distancing
um which was very important in the early
stages of covet 19.
really understanding where people are
leaving the home so in these maps you'll
see yellow as being
more people than normal being out of
their home
as we head towards that greenish blue
that's in the middle of the scale at the
bottom that's
typical behavior pre-covered 19. as we
get into the dark purples that is
less behavior less movement behavior now
i want to zoom in on one specific area
to show a good example of how this data
can be used
so as we're zooming in here this is the
area surrounding toronto
which is the capital of ontario which is
the largest province within canada
to the north of the map you can see
these areas lighting up in yellow this
is a very remote and rural set of
communities
that are very popular for cottage goers
and one of the things we immediately
started finding the data is that there's
a large volume of people traveling
to these areas from the big cities
to try to get away from where crowds
were the concern here is it puts a real
strain on hospitals in these areas that
may only have one or two ventilators
available
at any given time and if there were to
be an outbreak in these communities it
would affect them much stronger than it
would a larger city that has more
ability to handle within their health
care system
so this was being used to understand
where to redistribute ppe
in order to really help in fighting
covid
another way of looking at this is the
public health lens and trying to
understand
which communities are interconnected so
that if an outbreak happens in one
community
you know which other communities are
likely going to be affected
so by looking at large aggregates of how
people travel from one city to another
we're able to start determining linkages
and how closely linked different cities
are
so this is looking at three steps from
vancouver so this is taking vancouver
and then going up to three steps away
and showing the interconnectedness of
communities
this can be used say if there is an
outbreak in vancouver
how long would it take to spread to
somewhere like parksville that you see
at the
north east side of the sorry northwest
side of the map
or how long it would take to spread to
hope what is what's the path of travel
for that and where would you see other
outbreaks happening before you see it
there
and this can be really critical in
trying to figure out how to stop
the spread of the disease
so there's a lot of numbers behind these
maps and bigquery is what really makes
this possible so we have 74 billion
records per month
coming in we have 275 000 unique points
mapped out to over 5 000 unique polygons
across the country
there's 522 days of data being used to
analyze this this includes things like
building baselines from previous years
understanding the existing data today
and going far beyond that to try to
predict what might happen in the future
and finally there's 1.2 petabytes of
data being analyzed this is a massive
massive amount of data
and we're able to do this 25 times
faster than we could with our previous
hadoop infrastructure
and that's really the power of google
cloud here is we're able to do this
just because we have bigquery gis we
couldn't do this with our previous
technology and we wouldn't have been
able to help in the fight against covet
19
without having the access to this kind
of technology
and again today we're announcing our
telus insights api which allows canadian
companies to get access to this type of
information
through a queryable api uh where they
can build out their own reports and
analysis of what's happening across
canada
and to get more information on this you
can contact myself or the telus insights
team through our website telus.com
insights and back over to you chad
so joe thanks for joining me uh in the
presentation
thanks for announcing the launch of uh
telus insights
uh in the presentation and also like
thanks for the work you're doing i mean
that's
uh it's just a really great example of
how we can bring these tools
and this data together like to do good
stuff for
people you know that need people that
need to understand this like
public uh policy decision makers so i
really appreciate that
so to wrap up everyone um by the way
this is the last slide so if you're
if you're tired we're just about there
so hang on um
but to wrap up i wanted to talk a little
bit about the context
um that we are or have developed here at
google
around geospatial analytics and how
we're thinking about all the different
areas of it
you can tell a little bit about this you
know we foreshadowed it with the rest of
the talk because we talked about imagery
we talked about
tabular so i just wanted to wrap that
all up with one slide
on the left side you see the types of
data that frequently go into geospatial
analyses right tabular imagery on the
bottom here there are preform data
assets
the earth engine catalog the descarte
lab catalog bigquery's own public data
catalog
um they're a bunch of assets that we
have just available for folks to
start working on in the center here
these are the capabilities
that a you know a wide-ranging
geospatial analytics practitioner will
need
they have to work on tabular data they
have to work on imagery maybe your use
case doesn't use one of those but
we need to build it out for those who do
um
the bottom ones here mapping and data
visualization right you need to be able
to get your results on a map otherwise
they're
kind of meaningless and we need to be
able to bring to bear
machine learning and artificial
intelligence into this
so that we can do predictive analyses as
well
once you bring all of those capabilities
together over these data assets
and types of data that are shown here on
the left then you get all of these use
cases
so the ones that i described earlier the
ones like joe described
and it really is our thesis here and
we're seeing this
being born out which is really exciting
that once you have these capabilities
available at the scale that they're
available at
inside of google cloud you can do your
analyses over much larger data sets
and do much more interesting and
ultimately impactful
analyses for your users for your
customers or for the public
so with that thank you very much for
spending a bit of time with us
my name is chad jennings and i'm joe
bettridge thank you very much